that of course is a danger and you could
say that the history of north and our
lid over the last 50 to 100 years
provides evidence for that having
happened on occasions but I think this
time it's possible to be a bit more
hopeful because the balance most of the
extra money most of the extra four
hundred fifty million pounds per on over
the next two years seems to be dedicated
towards investment in other words being
put into transport improvement digital
improvement or very importantly
improving the structure of the health
service here that I think gives some
grounds for hope that this is going to
help to improve the long-term
sustainability of growth northern
economy rather than being simply a sort
of proverbial short-term
sticking-plaster
so the British taxpayer may actually get
a bit of bang for their buck this time
then well hopefully yes there will be a
generator not just to Northern Ireland
but to the UK as a whole if it can lead
to the sort of potential for the North
Island economy to grow more rapidly so a
win-win situation isn't the problem here
though that I mean were northern islands
an independent country it would have a
deficit to GDP ratio something like 29
or 30 percent I mean it would be
completely incapable of standing on its
own two feet well that's right but of
course that's a hypothetical it isn't an
independent country it's a region of the
United Kingdom yes it does have a trumps
whereas it might be turned from the UK
Exchequer but so of course does every
region across the United Kingdom bar
London and the East and South East of
England so Northland is not unique in
that regard but it is true that insert
proportional terms are so-called
transfer or subsidies invention is large
but come back the same sort of point to
the extent that this money is well used
and invest it then conceivably in 10-15
years time and it is a long term
challenge that degree of subsidy or
support from the rather than economy
might be we might be a
to reduce it yes you mentioned some of
the other measures there that might
benefit Northern Ireland's economy are
in equivalents on corporation tax rates
with the Irish Republic that was one
area that the dup were pushing for it
doesn't look like they've got their own
way there no but you see the thing was
that that has always been conditional
and it remains conditional at least two
big things important things have to
happen to make it possible
we need the restoration of devolved
government here at stored at the North
now and of course we wait to see whether
that's going to be possible in the next
week or so and secondly any future or
restored government here has to
demonstrate that it has a sort of fiscal
stability the ability to balance its own
books to make that feasible how damaging
would it be for Northern Ireland if post
brexit a hard border with the Irish
Republic were imposed it could be very
damaging but it has to be said that all
the major political players London
government Dublin government are very
much on the same page here in terms of
saying that the common travel area which
has existed since Irish independence in
1921 should be preserved and as few
tariff and custom barriers as possible
should be there on the the land border
so it's a room for some optimism around
Northern Ireland's prospects post Bret
said I mean clearly the population in or
denial and voted to remain part of the
EU yes it did vote 56 to 44 percent in
terms of rebate in terms of optimism
it's it does pose an economic challenge
but provided that we get the policy
response rate and provided that we don't
use Breck's at the some sort of coverall
excuse for government or other types of
failures in the private sector I think
the northern economy can continue to
grow and indeed the available economic
forecast suggests that that will be the
case